in the Wilds of North London where I
live near Highgate cemetery is a grave
and a tombstone of the Wily old
political Economist who's the subject of
tonight's debate many of you may have
been there to pay homage or simply to
visit and reflect but the Revival of
interest in Karl Marx since the
financial crisis and the reason he's
here in spirit this evening is because
we're suffering as I'm sure you know an
attack of deep economic pessimism you'll
also know very well that our fixation
with this pessimism and crisis and
capitalism is not unique for example
John Maynard Keynes wrote about this in
1913 in a tract called The Economic
Consequences for our grandchildren in
which he said it is common to hear
people say that the epoch of enormous
economic progress is over and that a
decline in prosperity is more likely
than an improvement in the decade ahead
of us eerily familiar words but my view
is that keynes's dismissal of the
pessimism of his own time has relevance
today
and I'd like to argue two points first
that the whole point about the
contradictions of capitalism is not
specifically whether Marxism or Marx's
analysis is relevant which personally I
think in many ways it is but it's the
outcome it's the synthesis
and our capacity to basically nurture
and establish coping mechanisms and the
second point is that the main threats to
our economic and social model today come
actually from two sources that didn't
even exist until quite recently and on
neither the direct outcrop of capitalism
nor terminal
so the first point on Marx's Tombstone
as you'll know if you've been there
there's an inscription taken from the
Theses on firebach which says the
philosophers have only interpreted the
world in various ways the point however
is to change it which is precisely what
our antecedents have done by developing
coping mechanisms like institutions of
the rule of law limited liability
companies trades Union Mutual societies
Insurance welfare and technological uh
discoveries that drive productivity
income and jobs
finding those coping mechanisms is an
endless task and we need to make more
progress on at least three of them
the first is that we can't obviously
keep shifting income from the owners of
Labor to the owners of capital without
experiencing income inequality
impoverishment of workers relatively if
not absolutely excess capacity and
unemployment
stronger investment that we had in the
1990s and the 2000s has of course given
way to a bust real wages have been
stagnant or declining in this country
the median real wage has fallen by about
nine percent since 2009 back to levels
last seen in 2003 and the labor
compensation share of the national
income has fallen profit share has risen
by about five to ten percentage points
in most rich countries
the second point is that Finance or
second contradiction if you want is that
Finance has been an enabler of
innovation and growth but as articulated
poignantly by The Economist Hyman Minsky
30 years ago it's also an indeed
endogenous source of systemic
instability I'm sure this doesn't need
to go into any further explanation here
except to say that as the uh raconteur
and Economist and Diplomat JK Galbraith
once quipped about recurring bouts of
speculation and Euphoria from Rome
onwards every generation basically
suffers from a brevity of financial
memory and every generation makes the
species association between the
ownership of money and the possession of
intelligence
Bankers pay and The Wider issue of
management reuneration remuneration of
course are rarely out of the headlines
and an obvious grappling iron for
capitalism's critics but the problem is
that rent gouging or rent seeking as
it's more politely known is the result
of eminently fixable market and
corporate governance flaws we could for
example break up the banks as the Vicars
commission has urged we could ban or
restrict the use of stock options and
other tools that tire remuneration to
short-term stock market performance
there's nothing specifically systemic
about not being able to fix these
problems if we really want the third
point I just quickly mentioned is the
need to cope better with globalization
capitalism's propensity to globalize has
generally been a force for the good I'd
submit but the blowback in the form of
the growing economic significance of
China and other major Emerging Markets
is a big problem
integrating in their own ways Western
capitalism's best practices from markets
to modernity and from meritocracy to the
rule of law these countries are no
longer just consumers of Western
capitalism's goods and services and in
some respects clones but also very
powerful competitors and Rivals big big
contradiction issues without a doubt but
my point is that even if our existing
political leaders suffer from from
myopia and something that I like to call
deficit attention disorder
thank you uh the capitalists
the capitalist model has been and
remains adaptable now the two points I
mentioned earlier which are relatively
recent are 21st century aging and
technology which actually have in some
respects the flimiest flimsiest of links
to capitalism uh and are questionably
though big issues for example in the
first case weak fertility and rising
life expectancy are driving a unique and
Relentless rise in the age structure of
our societies never seen before and it's
challenging us to redefine the social
rights and obligations of citizens
versus the state it's a very complex
issue to get over particularly at a time
like this
and the thing about technology and
automation is that they are also
displacing White Collar including
skilled jobs from retail to radiology
and from clerical to even legal
positions and I think this explains
partly the predominance of low-income
part-time jobs in countries that even
have raised employment since 2009.
modern technology is equally an issue
for emerging countries for example in
China the Taiwanese company Foxconn who
as you know manufacturer for Apple Sony
and lots of others in China has started
to substitute robots for workers their
plan is to substitute one million by
2015.
Automation and robots are generating
very strong demand for labor at the top
of the occupational structure and the
bottom leaving as my opponent tristrams
said before those with average levels of
human capital and skill in the middle
very vulnerable and dragging income
inequality higher we don't really know
how we're going to solve this problem in
the long run
but capitalism still has very persuasive
credentials let me give you two little
anecdotes first
Henry Ford and a prominent labor leader
supposedly once teased each other about
Factory robots not being able to pay
union dues or buy more Motorcars
Henry just simply retorted or that he
was going to pay his workers twice the
going rate which he did which
underscores a process in capitalism that
runs from productivity to higher wages
and lower prices rising demand and jobs
and so on there's also a story about
Milton Friedman visiting a Chinese
construction project and asking his host
why workers were using so many shovels
and so few machines
told that this was a job creation
project Friedman said in that case why
don't you give them spoons
the point of course is that Capital
including human capital makes people
more productive and society's better off
in my hunch is that in time the
Revolution going on in advanced
Manufacturing in the energy sector and
new technology will deliver significant
benefits so in conclusion Mr chairman
our opponents May argue that capitalism
itself is the systemic problem behind
our pessimism and that markets don't
work that a radical redrawing of the
boundaries between the state and the
private sector is necessary personally I
don't think anyone thinks that
laissez-faire is the answer but we
should be careful what we wish for the
influential Chinese magazine kashin
warned the country's leaders recently
that the heavy stand of the heavy hand
of the state was stifling competition
distorting resource allocation and
encouraging corruption and red seeking
and social fragmentation China's leaders
have the courage and will to implement
difficult reforms in the next five to
ten years Chinese capitalism will move
our way if they don't we shall see
ladies and gentlemen finally our
predicament I would submit is not the
sound of capitalism falling apart but a
painful period of adjustment from one
economic and technological period to
another thank you